you're welcome to this video playing
Gaillard gellert hmm yeah from from
Spain and no he's really playing it
seemed clicking his time early on I'm
ahead on the clock yeah let's keep that
timed vantage again I'm trying for the
Kings Indian okay maybe now is scaling
foot down maybe you found this opening
book okay mom the from the four points
attack yeah main moves RC 596 then going
for 45 here who is taking this is a
dangerous line in fact which I don't
know well hmm i think as power of top
with the porn back in the ages didn t
not sure yeah the idea is if I go eat
five you will play an f5 and in fact a
five assists some idea here anyway not
easy yeah
I don't really know how long like is
supposed to play that
yeah maybe 94 maybe this is even what
Kasparov played bagman I I wakely
remember this game against Larry
Christensen and I think it was the the
some sort of intercellular tournament
something like that very important event
yeah but what what did it again not much
really nidus marry me get the night
activated be 82 c 6 I don't know I I
really have early am I really prefer
white yeah it looks it looks dangerous
okay this is a very artificial maneuver
but maybe if you place f5 I mean I can
take it all off efef GF and say okay
attack me I'm trying to defend him yeah
I don't know if this was any good okay
Queenie Troyer I can play h6 on that
exchange in Queens would be brilliant he
could of course them after move like and
it's a queen age for h-60 can try to
make a sacrifice out of it easily but I
don't really believe that this sum can
be completely sound yeah I have night
before now with 92 threatened and d3
hang so this should at least exchange
some stuff which is probably helpful
yeah night see two will get the dark
squared bishop may be here take care
night c 2 but not one hundred percent
sure if i should do that really the
nights are not bad really not but I get
yeah I get get two bishops for two
nights you know that this sounds very
tempting to me I guess you will take
would be strange to not take it yeah now
i'm getting the other bishop as well
here we go ok but if i plot it on d4 he
will probably just just sec the exchange
yeah but is it is so great i have e 5
available yeah it's not not clear that
this helps them mmm yeah very tricky the
Pawnee has also very weak okay but
Bishop d4 it also has clean h3 which is
quite nice fun now can playing on
consolidating move yeah I had the
suspicion that this is not really great
for me so the two bishops were too
tempting d66 is really weak maybe even a
move like em the instant nite nite beef
I if I could be good yeah or that one
that's that's very a very
clearly dangerous okay but it makes the
constructor somebody somebody did sorry
somewhat rigid so it's not clear that
that is so great time and be sure to see
six
life I've is also potentially week then
the question is what happens short term
like 90 for this kind of moves Queen h3
hangs the night this is not really great
yeah 96 okay but I'm going here going
here I want to put the bishop on c6 even
if it costs upon fancy 5 Quincy five
would exchange greens which must help me
in 95 I really don't believe it i also
have remove lagu f5 attacking me5 yes
that's that that's possible clearly but
I thought that at the end I'm getting
this important pawn and this is worth
more than I mean that the bishop should
be should be really great iam sorry I've
got 10 something in my throat ok 2 t-3
interesting yeah we'll take only six mmm
time warning I'm not so sure where to
put it it's not not so easy well it does
not do so much on the long diagonal I
rather keep an eye on this night again
no no the pawn on c5 you actually
something that i can attack go here it's
got 97 but I take d3m this the sense
Hank's the work on f1 as well could take
c5 now or or g5g five yeah that's the
problem with nights sometimes they turn
out to be clumsy clumsy pieces now I'm
winning one of them this one check just
going a five and Rob g8 it is relatively
easy from a technical point of view
check Brooksie 2 i'm going to win the
check to be born check check check
and what are those will fall as well
check check check you have the bonus
night for some time promoting yeah there
was a bit tricky but um it's it's always
hard to to to evaluate here okay you
know I have to serve those unhealthy
Bishop thing going now operates want one
two bishops and of course this is
excellent with two bishops for two
nights the question is if if this was
right i mean it probably should be okay
for me yeah the computers on 000 it
gives night d 6 cm bishop um all right
now it wants to exchange it gives us
about equal yeah the nights i mean
they're active no one no doubt about
that maybe I Eve had better continuation
here the computer wants to take on f1
and play will get eight with some
advantage yeah maybe that's true here in
this this now I'm pretty confident about
I think I should have at least excellent
compensation for the pawn yeah this I
don't like really it's not it's not
great it exposes the seaport it does not
really do much the computer wants to
take here check and take here get the
pawn yeah which I just from from general
grounds I thought should be about about
yeah compensation it's just that the
bishops are so strong
maybe night here not this Bishop before
it's also not so great yeah I'm always
threatening to take take off one of the
nights and do something like rook f2
it's not so easy here I'm threatening
Bishop d3 and then made him so what's
its it's tricky if you go here it does
not help I mean this Bishop is just a
long-range piece you cannot play g3 down
if you play something like that it runs
into this business again threatening
rook d6 that's already good for black so
it's it's a bit tricky computer wants to
do this this and now h3 after which at
least I can do that being a bit more
comfortable for me but ok white should
hold this of course my dear three and
yeah Knight to f3 rook let's say to see
two and just and just stay this is a
draw yeah so I think I'm I've
compensation for the porn it's not like
like as winning or anything but it can
easily turn out to be trickier here
right is in big trouble and he is yeah
this is close to being lost i guess but
ok hit the computer points on 95 which i
didn't really seem oh here look d8 was
stronger yeah first attacking that yeah
and i see the point this is this is much
much much more much more precise it's
not clear what you want a smooth as if
he moves the rock which sees this looks
like a good idea i go here and again
where's the night going it does not have
a great square i can go see I just just
grab this yeah Luke be one there's
nobody to and I'm invading yeah just
this is an excellent and game and very
tricky to play it's no wonder that he
quickly gave way material because it's
such as it's very awkward if you have
those nights and they don't have any
great stable outposts I mean this is not
a stable outpost on f4 and this
disposition would be much different if
you yet let's say porn on c3 knight on
d4 Knight only three which is a
fortress-like but here the nights are
simply depended on each other and can
easily yeah it was one of them alright
thanks for watching